this is a very early scene in the movie
where Moana had six six older brothers
and there was a canoe race between Moana
and her brothers and this was a showcase
for Mo Ana's sailing proficiencies and
how she really and out does her brothers
we lost the brothers and we wanted to
make her less proficient when she was
sailing so his scene went away but it's
a fun scene the scene went away as did
her six older brothers and all the way
out of them how she became an only child
and it probably as much happier as an
only child speaking of someone who has
five sisters and speaking of someone
who's an only child
on your lap - Moo go away this raises
boys only I see no reason for that I've
already beat in the middle
everyone beats the middle but this time
I'm getting Locker row
[Music]
ah look at what could go wrong go right
behind him
I knew he'd amount to something oh
thanks Bob achieve but now sitting this
one out
had some bad then
one
I'm going to be on that water tomorrow
nothing's getting in my way